Rochelle:
Hello.
I'm gonna try to do
something amazing here,
which is set up for my demo
while I'm talking.
So I'm gonna talk
about Google Apps Script.
It feels kind of natural that
you'd want to get your own data,
and then you
want to do things with it.
And so Google Apps Script lets
you do things with that data.
Let's you do things
across apps.
So I'm gonna actually log on
to a domain,
a test domain...
which has some examples on it.
Normally I would do this
before I came up here,
but we didn't have the luxury
of two machines here, so...
So I'll just quickly describe.
What Google Apps Script
does for you
is it lets you
automate actions across apps.
That's a fairly generic way
to say
that it lets you do things that
you would normally do manually.
It starts in spreadsheets.
It's intended to do
more than that.
But in spreadsheets, there are
very specific things you can do.
You can create
custom functions.
You can access and edit data,
formulas or formats.
You can do the things
that you would almost expect to
be able to do in spreadsheets.
And then it goes
outside of spreadsheets
to reach into Calendar,
to be able to create
and look at events,
to be able to look at Mail--
in a very limited way,
to be able to send mail, okay?
So there will be other things
you can do in Mail eventually,
but right now
it's just sending mail.
And you can do
other things as well.
Grab data from a Web page
and investigate it, look at it,
do things, act on it,
do URL Fetch, GET and POST,
and translate
to other languages.
So I'm gonna show you
some of those examples.
I'm gonna focus
on three examples.
The first is fairly simple.
It's a custom function.
And these custom functions
are extremely straightforward.
They're written in JavaScript.
All of Google Apps Script
is JavaScript
with the extensions
of the objects
that we give you access to.
So the way you access
Google Apps Script
is through the Tools menu.
And right now, just to clarify,
we're actually
in a limited test mode.
So you have to apply to get
your domain activated.
And once it is activated,
you can access it
the way I'm showing you now.
And I'll tell you now,
just in case you want to visit--
We actually have the link
linked from
the Google Enterprise Blog,
which is
googleenterprise.blogspot.com.
It's still--I'm not gonna go
into the detailed URL.
It's still the top post,
so you should be able
to find it no problem.
But from the Tools menu,
there's a Scripts submenu,
and you go to Edit Scripts.
And I'll just very quickly
show you the code
of these custom functions.
And a script can contain
more than one function.
So this script
is called Convert.
It's got two functions in it.
The first is the
inches-to-millimeters function.
It is definitely not
the best way, actually,
to write a function
that's gonna do conversion,
you know, to have each function
for every single conversion
you'd want to do,
but I just wanted
to illustrate the point.
You can see
it's just plain JavaScript.
There is a declaration
of variables.
There's a quick test
to look at the input
and to return something
in the cell
that says it's an error
if it is,
to do the simple calculation,
and then to return that value
to the cell.
So when you have
a custom function,
it's expecting an input,
and it's gonna basically
give you an output.
So what you can see here
is I'm calling that function
as a normal formula,
it's called in the spreadsheet.
And it's calculating
the result for me.
So if I change the input,
it's gonna calculate
the output.
So it's very standard.
And you can basically, you know,
do everything you can do
with a...
spreadsheet
once you have that function.
Again, my formats
are a little wacky there,
but I'll just show you quickly
how it would work.
If I'm doing parallel
calculation, it's gonna--
Oh, it didn't do
my extension for me.
I messed that up.
Sorry.
But you can see
what the gist of it is.
So in case any of you
are looking to convert
many inches to millimeters,
I'll sell you
this custom function.
This really, really took me
a long time to develop.
Actually, it literally took
about five minutes
to develop that one.
The longest time
was just going to Google Search
and figuring out what the factor
was to multiply by.
I didn't have
that one memorized.
So the second example
I want to show you goes beyond.
So you saw
how to actually access Script--
it's in the Tools menu--
and how to do a custom function
very simply.
And again, once you have data
pulled in through SDC,
there are things
you want to do with that data.
That's kind of the whole point.
This example might be
a little bit more relevant.
We use this one
in Google a lot now.
This is generally--
if you look at the generic--
the abstract of this example,
it's very popular,
which is forms are used...
prolifically at Google
and other customers.
And one of the things
you want to do
is look at the data
that came in on form,
the same way you'd look at data
that came in through SDC,
and do stuff with it.
This one is going to send
confirmation emails.
So you can manipulate the data,
potentially, that came in
or look at it and prove it
and send emails.
What I want to show you
in this example is the two ways
that you can execute a script.
And this script
is not a custom function.
This one is just processing.
The two ways
are through a drawing object.
A drawing object
can be assigned to macro.
So you'll see
I can have a small menu--
it's a little bit hidden
under my scroll bar there--
that I can assign a script,
and I assigned a name
to that script--
"Email Confirm."
And the other way
is through a custom menu.
So you can see
the Confirm custom menu
with just one option here,
which is Send Confirm Emails.
What this script does
is it looks at this field
to see was this confirm
ever sent?
And if it was, it won't send it,
but if it's not, it will.
So I'll click on that button,
and it's running the script.
You can see it started, and now
it's marking them as sent,
and it's giving me
a time stamp as well.
So if I wanted to resend it,
you know, I could basically
blank this out and resend,
and it'll send it again.
So I'll quickly jump to--
Well, I shouldn't say quickly,
'cause I'm just not fast enough
typing when I'm presenting.
But I'll jump
to my Mail account,
so you can see the email.
The email that came in
was defined by my script.
My script said, "What do I want
that email to contain?"
So you can see
all those responses just came in
within the last minute.
And the contents of that email
is defined by my script.
I put in there what I wanted to
in the format that I wanted.
So it's an HTML string,
basically,
that I sent out to that email.
I could also create attachments
and formulate those attachments
and put them
in that email payload as well,
and they would come through
as attachments,
which is kind of neat.
We actually do that--
For the documentation
of this product,
we're creating
the documentation
in an automated way
using script.
We have a spreadsheet
that contains
all of our documentation,
and anybody on the team
can go in and change things,
fix things, whether
they're engineers or not,
and then somebody
pushes a button,
and it sends all that stuff
over to the Webmaster
to put it in the Help Center.
So it's really
an interesting way to--
I have to say, the attachment
process was created--
that feature was created
specifically for the team.
I guess when it's something
that they're asking for,
they get to put it
at the top of the list.
So the third example
is translation.
This is using
another one of these objects,
these beans,
which also illustrates
one more point,
which is just analyzing,
or using,
my currently selected range.
So this is a rather,
in some ways, dumb function,
which is it's just gonna take
what I selected.
It's gonna translate it
and throw it to the right.
It's just gonna put it
in that highlighted area
that I have to the right.
And again, I created
a menu option for that,
and I, in this case, created
four different caller functions
so that the menu can be
a little bit more user friendly.
And I'll say, "Let's translate
that to Spanish."
It started running the script.
You can see down below,
it's doing the translation.
And when it finishes, it'll say
that the script is finished,
and the results are there.
Again, like I said,
there's so much you can do
from that point.
This is really
just to illustrate.
One of the, you know,
really obvious examples
is to be able to translate
content and email
to someone who's not even
on the product.
So you can actually do
translation
and send information
to customers or partners.
I'll show you one more thing
that's just--
at the risk of it not working
just because I wrote it
late last night--
which is a conversion function.
Since I showed you the wrong way
to do inches to millimeters,
I'll try to show you
a better way.
This is actually translating
different things.
And what I did
is I'm translating
from U.S. dollar to Euro.
And, you know,
that should work.
Let's see if it changes that.
But I can also say, "I want
to translate from feet to--"
I don't know,
somebody give me--
What do you want
to translate feet to?
Yards.
Hey, 30 feet is 10 yards.
Yeah, I can even--
You know, I can do liters
to gallons.
Pretty much anything.
And the way I do that
is through URL Fetch.
I'm using Google Search.
I'm using the in operator.
I don't know
if anybody's ever used that.
But I just basically formulate
the search string,
and then
when the payload comes back,
I look at the string,
and I came up with a very--
This is what--You know, the only
thing that took any time
was I look at that data
that came back,
and I find the answer.
So if you look at this script,
it's fairly simple
but convoluted.
This is a great sign
of my horrible coding.
But it's--you know,
it's mostly comments, actually,
but I have to find the third
table and find the equal sign
and look for the units,
and I'm there.
But it's just an example
of how to actually call out
to external services,
whether they're your own
or something else,
through the URL Fetch option.
And that's pretty much it.
The most important thing here,
I think, is the extensibility.
We're gonna be adding--reach out
to other Google apps,
as well as non-Google apps
at some point.
But very shortly,
you'll be seeing
enhancements to this.
Like I said, go to the
googleenterprise.blogspot.com
if you want to apply to have
your domain in this limited test
that we're doing right now.
It's likely
you can be accepted into that,
and fairly soon you'll see it
launched across
all of Google apps.
That's it.
Thanks.
[applause]
Do you want to take
questions now?
Do we have time for questions?
Great.
Do they have the mic on?
man:
There we go.
Question about--two quick ones,
one about the email.
You mentioned that you
can put attachments on that
before sending out the email.
Can you format the attachments
to be in-line
or just payload attachments
on an email?
Are there ways
of configuring that so that--
Say, can you format it as HTML?
Rochelle:
You can pretty much do anything.
In other words, that attachment
is really, literally,
just a bitstream.
It's a blob.
man: Okay.
The other one is,
you mentioned--
In the little script
you wrote to convert,
you looked
for the unit character.
How do you find the units?
Rochelle: It's really
just pattern matching,
and it just took some testing,
to be honest.
I mean, if you could see me
writing this thing,
it was almost funny,
'cause I just kept returning
whatever I could find
until I narrowed down,
and then I had to find
some crazy ASCII character
that represents a comma.
It was insane.
But it was simple to write
and then hard to perfect,
and I would say
it's still not perfect,
but it is useful, actually.
man: So one thing I haven't seen
yet or heard anyone talk about
is what are the scalability
and deployment guidelines
for the Secure Data Connector
on my server?
I mean, it's deployed to one box
is what it looks like here
via 50,000 employees.
How is that gonna work?
How many boxes
does it deploy to?
What's failover?
Can you guys talk
about that at all?
man #2: There's more
documentation on the site,
but in short, basically,
you can run multiple instances
of the SDC agent
and the failover
to each other.
man: Okay.
man #2: Yeah.
Rochelle:
Any other questions?
man #2:
man: When is this
gonna be broadly available?
Rochelle: I'm sorry.
Say that again.
man: Accessing data,
say, you know,
behind corporate firewalls
and whatnot.
Rochelle: Secure Data Connector?
man: Yeah.
man #2: What I have demoed today
are all in production,
so you can do it today.
And all the--The two products
are Open Source products,
so you can download
and configure them yourself.
Rochelle: Yeah, so the limited
test that I was talking about
was literally
for Google Apps Script,
not for Secure Data Connector.
man: What about dynamic data
in forms?
man #2: What--Oh.
man: Spreadsheet forms.
Rochelle: I'm sorry.
man: Forms?
Spreadsheet forms.
Rochelle: Yeah, what about them?
man: I don't know if there's
a talk specifically on forms,
but a big need we have
is making dynamic forms--
are more, you know,
responsive to actual data.
Rochelle:
Yeah, so one of the things
that we expect to add
to Google Apps Script
is event processing.
So I'm thinking--
Tell me if I'm wrong,
but what a lot of people
are asking for is to do things
like when a form submission
comes in, do something.
Is that what you mean?
man: Well, no,
actually pulling data,
creating dynamic questions...
Rochelle: Ah, okay.
man: from a data source.
So, yeah, that's interesting.
Since we don't yet have
a good API
into the forms capability
of spreadsheets,
we don't have anything on Script
that reaches into that.
But we do expect to do that.
It's just not there yet.
Yeah, forms is an incredibly
popular feature right now,
so we expect to do
a lot more with that.
Okay, looks like we're done.
Thanks.
man #2:
Thank you.
[applause]